well the migrant caravan is fake you've
been watching CNN so you know that look
at this graphic quote invasion unquote
than the word myth on the screen it's a
myth a pernicious one - is it actually a
myth well filmmaker I mean Horowitz
decided to find out himself he went to
Mexico looking for this fake Caravan he
found a real Caravan and he filmed it
here's part of what he found
despite the framing of the caravan is
being full of women and children the
reality on the ground is quite different
approximately 90 to 95 percent of the
migrants female the major narrative
being pushed by the press has been that
the migrants are leaving Honduras
because they're escaping extreme
violence and that their lives are under
constant threat
setting up the strategy that they would
be able to enter the US by asking for
asylum so I started by asking them a
simple question why are you coming to
America well know what was going on on
our beer
there's a massive logistical effort
underway akin to moving an army and is
clearly costing someone millions of
dollars for the transportation food
water medicine and services that are
being provided for the members of the
Caribbean the Mexican government also
seems to be sending police to escort the
dozens of buses and trucks that are
faring the migrants and supplies along
the route to the next destination
ever-present among the thousands of
migrants are workers of Pueblo
sinfronteras clad in black t-shirts and
colored vests webelo sinfronteras means
people without borders
they're the ones that seem to be most
involved in organizing and mobilizing
this caravan the organization as the
name implies is looking to create a
world without borders which seems to be
one of the reasons why they organizes
caravan the first place to flout
American sovereignty while it does seem
as the majority of these migrants are
friendly and simply trying to make a
better life for themselves and their
families there's an undeniable element
of the migrants who are violent and
dangerous and many of the migrants know
this and some of the experienced it
seems to me that there are leftist
organizations that are using these
migrants as a tool to push a certain
political agenda which includes the
weakening of American sovereignty and
our border security and unfortunately
these migrants are going to be caught in
the crossfire
I mean Horowitz joins us tonight that
was really interesting the thing that
jumped out at me was how as you said
well-organized it was do we have any
sense who's paying for this I know we're
not allowed to speculate but do we know
that answer we don't we know what we do
know is this whole thing cost millions
and millions of dollars and and the
mainstream media and there's so many
layers to this onion to peel back it's
hard to know where to begin but one of
the lies the fake news if you will that
the mainstream media is trying to
propagate is the fact that this is all
this weird organic thing and all the
water and the food and the medicine all
dropped from miner from heaven it's
baloney it's all highly organized it's
paid for by a number of organizations we
don't know exactly where the money's
coming from we do know that that Pueblo
of sin Fronteras which is the the main
group which organizes caravan has a
couple of front organizations in the
United States and the money is flowing
from them to prevalence of Fronteras we
know there are some leftist groups I
know it's it's it's forbidden saying
that source is part of it but Soros has
in fact funded at least some of those
groups in the past so we don't know
where the money is exactly coming from
we know it's not coming from Honduras so
why would I mean it's such an
interesting and obvious question who's
paying for this why have an other news
organizations gotten to the bottom of
this you're one man you're doing this
independently
why isn't NBC News or ABC or PBS why
aren't they on this oh come on you know
the answer to that they don't want to
get to the bottom of it they have no
they have no interest politically it
gained to the bottom of it it's the same
reason why whenever you see when you see
a photo of the New York Times The
Washington Post or a video in in CNN or
the BBC or MSNBC what do you see you see
the whole the entire framing or women
and children when the reality is so far
from the truth
90 to 95 percent of all the people in
this Caravan are men although I do
apologize for assuming their gender
they're liars that's that's the answer
that's why they aren't reporting than
you are because they are liars I mean
thank you for that that was valuable and
really interesting appreciate better